oh my god
oh they're the weirdest animal ever
g'day i'm the resident nature nerd at
abc science
we got plenty of deadly animals here in
australia
[Applause]
so now it's time to look around the
world
go impala and today we're taking a deep
dive
into dangerous aquatic animals
from those with huge jaws
you got him big time to murderous
mollusks
that is such a stupid thing to do and
i'm also going to speak to a ranger
who's had some close calls with deadly
dinosaurs
we've trolled the internet for the best
videos oh my god
oh my god to discover which of these
five animals
are truly deadly
hippos the aquatic mammal that can't
even swim
how is it that a mostly vegetarian
river giant like that can be one of the
most dangerous animals in all of africa
oh no out of water in the daytime oh no
so one of the things that hippos do is
use their incredible jaw as
like a rabbit trap they'll open it up
and they can open up a
huge amount 150 degrees
and then chomp down like
i don't know a death trap and that looks
like it might have happened in this case
that
the hippo actually charged and chomped
and that is a
deadly combination they're good on land
and they're pretty damn good in water as
well
whoa
look at the waves it makes it looks like
a special
effect like a movie
that is huge that is so
cool and also in that slo-mo you see one
of the adaptations or behaviors that
they do
that that enables them to dive deep
under the water
when it comes up you'll notice that its
little nostrils which have been closed
under the water open when they're up in
the air i suppose like a
blowhole from a whale they just
hippos are incredibly dangerous
and hippos have been known to tip things
like kayaks
and it is thought that hippos are
responsible for
something like 500 deaths every year
in africa but most of those aren't from
boat capsizing but rather from people
entering into a hippos territory
from the water's edge so there's a lot
of people dying from hippos
look at this little beauty ah look at
those little ears
it looks like mom might get hippos are
found in lakes and rivers
all throughout sub-saharan africa from
sudan
in the northeast all the way down to the
pointy bit
south africa so they're called
hippopotamus amphibious amphibious means
that they are both
on land and in water and hippopotamus
comes from greek roots it actually means
water horse look at that booty
i actually think they could be called
land whales though
because their closest cousin on the
taxonomic tree is actually
whales
[Music]
tiny i mean in saying that they're born
at about 45 kilograms so
it's not tiny that is adorable
they'll stay in the water for like 16
hours a day and they're nocturnal
they'll come out
at night and that's when they do their
grazing they are mostly vegetarian they
eat something like
45 kilograms of grass every day
you can imagine how much hippo crap that
is it's a lot of hippo crap
[Music]
it's like a helicopter
how amazing are hippos there are so many
different ecological benefits
from the moving between land and water
and one of the weirdest ones has to do
with silicon
and poo
silicon is a building block of life
forms
it's the little structures that diatoms
build themselves out of
now diatoms are single cellular life
forms that form
essentially the basis of the food web
so what the hippos do is eat kilograms
of grass
every day one of the things that's in
the grass is a whole heap of silicon
the hippos then acts like a bit of a
silicon conveyor belt
keep it in their tummy get all the way
back into the water
and crap it out the silicon goes out
into that watery ecosystem
and the diatoms are able to suck it all
in and reproduce
reversed someone's having too much fun
there
because they eat so much grass
scientists thought that hippos were
vegetarians
they are it turns out they're not very
strict
we have a standoff here an unusual
scandal for this part of the world we've
got a crocodile
and an impala
this is fascinating oh god now
the impala might make a run for it oh
it's going to be in trouble now this is
going to give me a heart attack oh this
is unbelievable stuff
here comes a hippo in two go impala
there's a hippo coming in
i can't believe what we're seeing here
this is what we'd normally see in east
africa
it's all over hippo leaping at the
crocodile now
it's precisely what we expected to
happen wait if something came up two
hours
took a leap there what's going on there
i think they've grabbed the crocodile
where did the second one come from
hippos don't like crocodiles it's
because crocodiles can prey on
their young so yeah when they see them
in their territory they're likely to see
them off the premises
oh look at how many there are they are
it's going for us
wow oh crocodile ain't looking good for
you mate
you can see that these hippos are
feeling aggressive you're seeing some
really big yawns that show off their
main weapon those big teeth
those huge jaws that can clamp down
in fact the charge and chomp
apparently ripped in half a four meter
crocodile once
that's how powerful a hippo chomp is got
it
goddamn big time
so if you're kayaking you need to stay
away from hippo areas and if you know
that you're in a hippo area maybe bang
the side of the boat and make lots of
noise so that they know
that you're coming along don't sneak up
on a hippo
[Music]
octopus these mollusks are pretty freaky
but how are they dangerous
oh god that
looks to me to be like a blue ringed
octopus one of the most highly venomous
animals in the world and one of the ones
that we do not have an anti-venom for
that is such a stupid thing to do that
is such a stupid stupid thing to do
a bit of octopus anatomy for you right
they've got a little beak and it's right
in the middle of their body
underneath and that's the bit that they
inject venom with
so it needs to actually drop down onto
its prey
to be able to kill it
so these guys are literally playing
russian roulette
how they create that venom is actually
in their salivary glands they've got a
little bacteria in them
and it creates tetradotoxin that is
an incredibly strong chemical that is a
neurotoxin
so the first thing that's going to
happen is you're going to start to feel
like your arms and legs are a bit numb
or tingly
your speech will become impaired you
might vomit then you'll become paralyzed
and won't be able to move
you'll still be fully conscious but
you'll likely die from lack of oxygen
it's not a pleasant process to go
through and if you do see a blue ringed
octopus
take a photo and don't touch it
look at these spots
[Music]
whoa so
this is a day octopus right and they're
soft-bodied it means that they're
really very vulnerable to attack
so they use camouflage
[Music]
they can change their colors using
chromatophores
and they can also change the texture
using these little lumps that they can
sort of bring up and it means that see
how the bottom
of the ocean in this part is sort of
lumpy and algae it can make itself
look like it's got the lumps look at
that
that is so cool i do believe that this
octopus has probably been disturbed by
this diver
and that's why it's doing such
visualization
[Music]
and that's a great view of the texture
that it can change
make itself look like it's a completely
different object
what a performance
it's gonna be cool you see that slot no
way you can't get it you
are wrong my friend
now octopuses can be very small or very
large but the important thing is they
don't feel restricted by their size
he can go through anything that is uh
that his vehicle fit through
a giant pacific octopus is giant it's
the biggest octopus that there is
a lot of them grow to about five meters
which is
sort of terrifying if you watch he's
gonna go right through there
[Music]
octopuses aren't shapeshifters they're
invertebrates and that means they don't
have
an internal skeleton they've got that
little bony beak
and they've got a bit of cartilage that
protects their brain but apart from that
it's malleable that means that they can
fit through
tiny holes they can spread out wide like
a parachute and they can do
all sorts of things it's frankly i'm a
bit jealous
the octopus brain is different than the
human brain
they have what's called decentralized
intelligence
it means that there's a core of brain
it's like a donut
it's in the bell part of their body
all the way out their arms they have
neurons which is sort of crazy to think
about and it means
that if an arm gets chopped off it'll
actually continue to do the action that
it was meant to be doing
even though it's disembodied from the
main part of the octopuses
intelligence there's his nose he's just
all the way through it now
except for oh just watch
yeah oh dear
[Music]
you're not going to get it off either
because if you remove one arm it's got
like
seven other arms there are documented
cases of
octopus attack but the thing is almost
all of them
have a backstory right where the octopus
was provoked
in some way
[Music]
divers who regularly dive say that one
of the most important things to do
is to protect your air source it must be
like
trying to fight angry jelly
if it wanted to it could potentially
really injure this bloke
is he saying take a photo
hello i'm here from the future to warn
you that the next clip
made me make an eek face it's a bit
disturbing so
keep that in mind
look at those suckers i think i remember
seeing this
at the time it's filmed overseas and i
think that this girl was making a series
about eating
live seafood which is common in some
cultures around the world
but in the case of octopuses it's
probably not a good idea
look at it pulling her eye
so what is amazing about seeing this
octopus attack this vlogger's face
is that you can actually see how nimble
each individual sucker is they can
really
actually rotate and move they're
incredibly strong
and you can get octo-hickeys from them
so i wouldn't be surprised if the day
after she was
actually bruised she did get a cut
quite frankly she got off lightly
it's also really dangerous to eat
octopus
arms that are freshly taken from the
octopus because
they've got that decentralized nervous
system it means that they keep wriggling
for quite some time
sometimes in excess of 15 minutes and
there have been cases of people eating
fresh octopus arms and actually choking
because as they go down
the suckers suck on to the inside of
their throat
so let that be a lesson
most octopuses are actually really shy
and retiring
they like to hide away and avoid
confrontation
so to avoid getting an octopus hug
from eight very strong neuron filled
sucker-lined arms the best thing to do
is give them
space space that they can go about their
octopussy business
and we can admire them from afar because
there's so much to admire
[Music]
we've got even better videos to come so
stay tuned
we usually think of sea lions as
harmless and
playful and like doggos of the sea
so why are they getting reputation for
being so aggressive
hey he's fighting my kayak
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing one of the ways you
can tell this is a sea lion and not a
seal
is because it's got little external ear
bits
seals have holes sea lions have little
external ears
he wants myself yes he does want your
fish
he got his fish don't bite me your
fishy's here
that is a risk
he knew it was coming he knew he was
doing the wrong thing
this is often how interactions with wild
animals go
you see it clearly had got fish off
fishermen before because it just kept on
harassing them until it got what it
wanted
and that's why feeding animals is bad it
habituates them
to human contact and then that can
impact negatively on the humans and also
on the animals
but yeah what a pretty little thing
[Music]
hi look at the little whiskies
it still disappears in that water though
doesn't it
that's definitely a male because it's
got that big forehead quite
flat it's probably a california sea lion
feeding it why would you do that
it is so dangerous
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
crikey that's why you don't feed animals
it habituates them to being around you
and expecting
every animal is different and you never
know how one is going to react
there were so many signs circling back
around
locked eyes it started to lift itself
out of the water before it even lunged
like i mean
so many signs
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god though this was a
pretty aggressive sort of attack
i don't think there's many fatalities
from sea lion attacks
at least not that i've heard of yet
oh that's so dangerous because these air
pipes are like right there
getting the shot though
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh those teeth really strong teeth
and as they age they often become black
because of bacteria in the mouth
it's probably a young seal maybe it's
exploring the texture of the wetsuit
maybe
it's just being naughty
[Music]
that's terrifying
that charging blowing bubbles barking
that's the sort of thing that says from
the sea lion get the hell out of here
[Music]
so the sea lion they're generally more
curious
than they are aggressive but they can
deliver a
nip and that can be bad on top of that
that can have a really massive infection
so it's best to keep
your distance after all it's in the name
lion see lion you don't go close to it
[Music]
for a creature that's been around for
200 million years it's
actually really surprising how
widespread crocodile species
are they're found in 26 countries in
africa alone
and that species is named after that
huge river
denial oh
oh my god when a croc is lucky enough to
actually
capture its prey item we've got
something like
65 teeth it's not necessarily the teeth
that you've got to be worried about it's
the bite force this is
incredibly rare to see there's another
crocodile coming in now the most
of any animal in the world that they've
been able to measure so far
big one in front around the world
there's an estimated 1 000 people that
die
every year from crocodile attacks it's
definitely
more fatal than sharks
now we're on to the sunshine state of
the us florida
pete you're too close to him it's really
asking for trouble isn't it when you
take out a camera when you're in a canoe
you just know it's going to end poorly
oh god
pete your pedals are close to that one
[Music]
sorry sorry
these are really cool reptiles their
whole
structure around their face is built so
that they can pretend to be a stick
it got pretty good hearing so when he
lets out these little screams
the crocs probably heard it they've got
little holes with flaps that are behind
their eyes
and actually their ear canals are really
interesting they sort of don't have two
separate ears like we do but rather a
tube that goes all the way through their
head
which is uh which is sort of cool but
yeah they can hear pretty well
the crocs would have known that they
were there for sure
mud skipper
[Music]
why is it that they always stop there's
never any closure on these things
ah that seemed to be a little croc and
it looks like it was that
ambush behavior like it just popped up
out of nowhere and was like wrong
probably would go for the mud skipper
but it might have been attracted by the
movement of the tourists
so that is something to think about just
wandering along beside a waterway
is a dangerous thing to do
little doggo there's a big croc there
mate
whoa
she's gonna thong it
yeah it backed off
bloody worked
[Laughter]
that is the most australian thing i have
seen
not in the recommended playbook when it
comes to dealing with crocodiles
so the recommended advice if you see
crocs or you're in crop territory
is to spend as little time as possible
at the water's edge
and also to move about your position at
the edge of the water so
instead of going every day at the same
time to get water
from the river you want to move up and
down
the bank so you're not predictable for
the crocodile
for some people including indigenous
australians crocodile attack is a daily
risk
i spoke to ranger greg wilson who has
regular run-ins with crocs
you meet my three dog too my brother dog
damn my nephew bitten by a brother of me
playing really fast i can grab you
spin you twist you they come up from
nowhere
you know they come up to you here don't
drive me if you want to get rid of him
hit him really hard
you know really high you better be
really fast
with that otherwise you might
really think then your job you know they
call australia the lucky country but
i i don't think that's what they were
talking about
[Music]
it's no surprise crocodiles are deadly
but their attacks are pretty rare and
they're mostly preventable
remember if you're near the water your
safety
is your responsibility not the crocs
[Music]
yep it's the biggest scariest fish in
the ocean
the great white shark sharks
what do we got here a spear fisherman in
south africa
okay that means there's potentially
blood in the water if you've been lucky
enough to
get a fish
okay i thought the rock was a shark then
this is why i'm not a diver whoa hi hi
it's like a charge that that shark just
did came out of nowhere
turned away at the last minute that was
saying move out of my territory
so it looks like it's actually a small
shark
there's a chance that it might be just
as scared of the diver as the diver is
of it as in they both just like scared
each other as they came around the
corner of the rock and
you know it was just a misunderstanding
incredible but he did do the right thing
he got out of there
all right here we are in urunga in new
south wales
it's chasing me wow
wow oh that went close
hey dad come here please yeah you come
over here into
the dead danger zone holy
that's a big white he's very interested
in me
like it's shaking it's the little leg
pumps is like
worst predator in the world
i can hear him coming like a paddling i
can hear him thumping away behind me
to me this behavior isn't attacking if
it wanted to attack him and kill him it
probably would have done so
it just seems more curious
splashing the water and with your paddle
probably isn't the best thing to do
because
what it says to the shark is that
perhaps there's something that's in a
little bit of distress that's
quite interesting there in the water so
yeah that's probably not the recommended
thing to do in fact
you probably want to be as uninteresting
as possible but
if a shark does attack you it is a very
good idea to
use the paddle to boop it on the nose
it's got quite sensitive little schnoz
and on top of that you can go for the
eyes as well
caveat on that very important not to
boop
a shark that's just saying hello and
being curious
you don't want to escalate things with
the shark just wants to
check you out rather than attack you
wow look at
you it see that the shark is just going
for the cage
that is such a good shot the shark teeth
are amazing they're serrated and you can
see that they point
backwards into the shark's mouth it's
essentially
a huge set of fish hooks that go into
the flesh and it means that
even if you tried you're not going to
get away you're just going to push
yourself deeper into these razor sharp
serrated teeth so if a great white shark
wants to get you yeah it's going to get
you
we got a big great white out there
we recommend get out asap there's a big
great white
shark out there
australia records the highest number of
shark fatalities in the world
but there are some things that we can do
to make sure we get a warning before the
sharks get too close
yeah i'm on it bro one of them is drones
that are used to basically spot the
shark and give warning to people to get
out of the water
no don't go out there's a big great
white out there
it's actually so beautiful and calming
to watch it and that's what 99
of the time our interactions with these
animals are
worldwide about four people die
every year from shark attack but
every single year a hundred million
sharks and rays
are removed from the world's ocean by
commercial fishing
the disparity is just amazing these
aren't really a risk to our well-being
in fact
they aid our well-being he's over there
yeah
when you take out these top order
predators the fish
that normally would be kept into control
by great white sharks
might proliferate they eat all of the
plants the sea grass meadows
these ecosystems are incredibly
important
in combating climate change because they
sink
carbon so what we must do
is include in conservation planning
these top order predators because
their part along with every other
organism below them
is critical to our future survival
oh yeah sharks are
absolutely deadly
in all senses of the word but when it
comes to avoiding a bite
really it's all about perspective and
prevention
you're much more likely to die of
drowning than you are of a shark bite
and if the shark bite is truly a fear of
yours then the answer is
not going in the water
so there you have it some of the world's
most dangerous aquatic animals
sure they can be scary but there's
plenty to be
impressed by from the highly evolved
apex predators
with their incredibly sharp senses
to the giant mammals whose poo breathes
life into whole ecosystems
[Music]
and then there's the ones that have
three hearts blue blood
and neurons in their arms see you next
time
[Music]
thanks for watching and if you like this
video why don't you click around because
on avc science we've got
heaps of videos that are just like this
in fact we upload them
every single week so it's worth hitting
subscribe and
i'll see you here next time